almost every project I've done since
Harry Potter oh I felt really rescaled
to start oh my god if I don't do this
nothing else makes sense like I I don't
want to spend my time doing anything
other than making sure that this maybe
gets made they say that every saint you
know has a past and every sinner has a
future and it's so true
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
and I want to see that great thing that
you have inside of you come out so you
can help change the world so to help you
in your journey today we're going to
learn from actress model and activist
Emma Watson and my take on her top 10
rules for success
rule number 9 is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always guys as
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down in the comments below and
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired and when you write it down
it's much more likely to stick with
yourself as well enjoy
what I know about Bell is that she's
kind of if you look at her within the
sort of the category of those Disney
characters she's kind of the rogue she's
a she kind of like she she takes a
different course that was always what I
loved about Belle like when I think
about Belle I think about her singing
Belle reprieves which is her sort of
coming out of her house and singing this
song which is just kind of like bursting
out of her which is you know I know
everyone around me can't understand why
I don't want what everyone else thinks
that I should one and which is being
handed to me but I really just want
something more I want something else
like I don't this doesn't fit I don't
fit she kind of liked the Robert Frost
poem she she takes the road less
traveled and I always really identified
with that she's Bala's no sheep she's
really on her own just on her own path
she's friends with sheep though it's
fast sheep she is special she but she's
on her own thing and there's this like
defiance and I just that that energy
that spirit was really what I identified
with in her being a child star as they
call it or having worked as a miner
you do you do sort of have to be aware
of the of the of the kind of trajectory
and also kind of aware the that people
are viewing your performances through a
very different lens it's I saw a really
interesting article yesterday that you
know people had seen the trailer and
they're like oh you know Emma Watson
like scandalous like really trying to
push the push the envelope and step away
from her mining Harry Potter and
whatever else and it's like I'm just
kissing someone you know and it's kind
of like this huge deal and it's so you
know you're aware of that but you also I
don't like to try and let all of that
noise affect my choices and like
decisions because ultimately if you live
like that then you you know I think it
would it would close me off to a lot of
opportunities and and experiences
there's a lot of young actors and
musicians today they they kind of spin
out of control a little bit why are you
so good at just like making your career
is amazing and you're just making the
right decisions later oh thank you
that's pretty nice to hear um I guess I
just I've just been really lucky in a
sense that I've been offered a really
diverse and interesting range of roles
and I've just tried to do things that
slightly terrify me every time I guess I
mean most almost every project I've done
since Harry Potter I've I felt really
reese cared to start so I've just kept
trying to challenge myself really
I play Nicki in The Bling Ring and how
perfectly Nicki Nicki writes yoga and
cheese cleanses and she teaches pole
dancing she's this very complex girl and
character stylist she was kind of boyish
kind of a tease and it's kind of like
nothing I've done before
to research the part I learned pole
dance
I watched a lot of reality television I
did yoga I did a lot of thinking about
how you'd get into the mindset where you
would think that stealing is okay it was
really important to me that I felt like
I understood her and I could relate to
her and she felt like a real person you
had a choice of you went to college and
and you had a choice than to either
continue acting or pursue something else
you majored in English literature right
what made you decide that acting was
then going to become the main event and
not just something you used to do puck
sipping a Wallflower really really yeah
it's so funny because I I went to
college and I was genuinely kind of like
well I'm gonna go study and then I'll
all kind of like I'll see what happens
and then Steve sent me the script for
Parks having a Wallflower and I went and
I sat down with him and it just we
ignited there so I was like had you read
the book before you really know I hadn't
so I read the book and it just gave me
this weird compulsion I was like I have
to tell this story
you know I oh my god if I don't do this
nothing else makes sense like I I don't
want to spend my time doing anything
other than making sure that this movie
gets made
I must go to Pittsburgh Pittsburgh I
must get funding for this movie you know
and it's like and it was really strange
because I just didn't know coming out of
Harry Potter whether I was going to feel
that way about anything else for a long
time you know I had loved performing and
I had loved acting but really a big part
of the passion for me was that I would
just loved those stories and I wanted to
be part of that world
I loved that who that that character was
and it wasn't so much for me about the
idea of being an actress it was the idea
of like I just want to be part of this
and perks and working with Steve and
feeling that I had something else to
give and offer was what really was
already did that for me everyone has a
story everyone has
people intent tend to judge and
interpret behavior without going to the
source of that behavior like they say
that every saint you know has a past and
every sinner has a future and it's so
true you can't I don't know people can
change and and people make mistakes and
people are human and you kind of need to
love them for love them for that and I
hope that people take that away finding
a way to love their imperfections and
love themselves and really you can't
truly accept other people until you
accept yourself and you can't really
accept yourself until you accept other
people it kind of all weirdly goes
hand-in-hand and when you show kindness
and compassion for yourself then you're
able to extend it and it's all it's all
inextricably linked I made these movies
you won't find that but also you've done
so well with all your great so this
sounds kind of odd number you've got
eyes and all your GCSE is that way and
in your higher levels as well yeah Wow
congratulations
yeah and it was tough it was really
tough
I felt very tall but um it was so worth
it you know I'm so excited about going
to university and you know I just won't
have my cake and eat it I want I want
the best of both worlds I want to do
everything the difficulty which means
I'm interested in so many different
things I can never really imagined
myself doing one thing and I'm pretty
sure that I'll end up doing four or five
different things I want to be a
Renaissance woman that's my that's my
thing I want to paint and I want to
write and I want to act and I want to
just do everything how do I drop my
career and become an actor what do you
think that's awesome you seem like the
kind of person you would want to watch I
want to be a film director do what you
love and make films about what you love
you can argue yourself into making
decisions that don't have heart behind
them and then never the right ones just
always follow the theme that feels the
most right to you
there's something about humor to me
which speaks to humility which which
speaks to yeah to being humble to being
human to it's such a way to connect
people and I think as long as you're not
taking yourself too seriously mm-hmm
nothing can go too badly wrong now
obviously talking at the UN is an
incredibly nerve-racking thing to do I
imagine I'm not going to only imagine I
haven't actually spoken at the UN yet
they haven't asked me yet but what what
was the the mission statement what was
going through your head in the morning
of that speech what was the mission
statement you wanted to get across I
guess I really wanted to communicate
that gender equality historically has
been predominantly a woman's movement
for women but I think the impact of
gender inequality and how it's actually
been affecting men hasn't really been
addressed so I really wanted to make
that one of the clearest messages in my
speech men don't have the benefits of
equality either we don't often talk
about men being imprisoned by gender
stereotypes but I can see that they are
and that when they are free things will
change for women as a natural
consequence if men don't have to be
aggressive in order to be accepted women
won't feel compelled to be submissive if
men don't have to control women won't
have to be controlled both men and women
should feel free to be sensitive both
men and women should feel free to be
strong it is time that we all perceive
gender on a spectrum instead of two sets
of opposing ideals
if we stop defining each other by what
we are not and start defining ourselves
by who we are we can all be freer and
this is what Heath
is about it's about freedom I want men
to take up this mantle so that their
daughters sisters and mothers can be
free from prejudice but also so that
their sons have permission to be
vulnerable and human to reclaim those
parts of themselves they abandoned and
in doing so be a more true and complete
version of themselves
you might be thinking who is this Harry
Potter girl what is she doing speaking
at the UN and it's a really good
question I've been asking myself the
same thing all I know is that I care
about this problem and I want to make it
better and having seen what I've seen
and given the chance I feel it is my
responsibility to say something
statesman Edmund Burke said all that is
needed for the forces of evil to triumph
is for good men and women to do nothing
in my nervousness for this speech and in
my moments of doubt I've told myself
firmly if not me who if not now when if
you have similar doubts when
opportunities are presented to you I
hope that those words will be helpful
because the reality is that if we do
nothing it will take 75 years or for me
it to be nearly a hundred before women
can expect to be paid the same as men
for the same work I am inviting you
to step forward to be seen and to ask
yourself if not me who if not now when
thank you very very much
how did you feel after you've done it
did you feel like you absolutely got
every point across did you feel that
that was that was the nice I love a
lovely moment like one of the most
surreal moments of my life I have to say
I remember at the end of it seeing
people start to stand up and it was like
something from a dream or a film or I
thought maybe I died and it was Irish it
was just really surreal we didn't die I
didn't die um but kind of a little bit I
felt like I could I sound really cheesy
but I felt like I could sort of die
happy like had sort of done kind of what
the most important thing I might ever do
I
I had I had I would I was shaking I was
so nervous but at least I I got it out
there like I'd managed to manage to
voice the words I've managed to I'd
managed to get it out I have to are
you're an amazing freestylers you just
can just do this you're an amazing beat
boxer this is great I eat books that
cave it show me how what am i doing okay
just well first let's to see no
instruction Oh
just from what you've seen I know you've
seen a lot of feed boxing I'm sure they
were beat boxing on set during those
movies every young man we just we just
beat box okay this could be so bad to be
awesome do I cover my mouth yeah just
for my sake yeah yeah yeah he's like
this bit dark so embarrassing okay what
am i freestyling about gender equality
fantastic it's you it's International
Women's Day
let's see fishy into other quick
feminism I know feminists yeah
absolutely I love that
okay so what kind of beat do you want
slow or fast
whatever you yeah yeah what's link and I
have to laugh how can we meet not easy
to we like like women are like all day
every day every way oh my gosh stick
this way to find them you know I'm
drastically changing the narrative you
know my gosh I love watching this keep
flowing holy cow this is such a meme
thank you this is the beatbox Dream Team
love you thank you
beatboxing everyone go see the play and
no one ever asked me to do that
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this food because rowdy Janie asked
me to if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you would like me to profile next
check out the link in the description
and go and cast your vote I'd also love
to know what did you learn from this
video that had the biggest impact on you
what lesson you're going to take and
immediately apply it somehow in your
life or in your business leave it in the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Robert Paladini Robert
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and tweeting at
me and giving me that really kind
message I really really appreciate this
board and I'm so glad that you enjoyed
the book thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
handing off Hermione Granger to Nomo
duma's whene'er on mm-hmm Harry Potter
in the cursed child yeah you've met her
and yes what were conversations like
about Hermione
it was so emotional seeing nomás
performance in a way that I had not
anticipated at all I went to the play
like really just like oh no this will be
great I'll be introducing and didn't
even realize until she walked in the
room and just spontaneous just burst
into tears it was such an emotional
moment for me I can't tell you but it
made me it was such a relief because I
think I'd played that character so
intensely up until that point to know
that Hermione was gonna be okay I know
it sounds crazy we're like to know that
everything turned out alright and the
wall everything in the world was okay
and that there was someone else carrying
her on and carrying her forward and it
was just such a relief it made me so
happy because otherwise I don't know
what playing someone that I mean we get
that little flash forward at the end of
the last film but playing someone that
kind of just gets stuck in time at 20 20
years old 19 years old was like no I
like I wanted her to have a future well
you see so many years of her life back
to back to back and then yeah nothing so
yet so it was sort of a relief yeah it
was a relief now did you have any
conversations with Pedro hara who voiced
the character no the animated a it's
interesting I've done a few movies where
I play you know someone play my
character before all that you know my
character exists in real life and I've
always chosen I've always chosen not to
I think because in the act of creation
you do you want to make sure that you're
that you're bringing something
individual and original and a big part
of it was wanting to stay faithful to
the to the original telling and I think
I hope we really got the balance right
of being like okay we're gonna offer you
some new stuff
that you've never seen before but we're
also going to give you the heart of
theory it's really quite shocking really
fir because this is something so out of
character and we've never he seen that
side to her before look who's here ah
come see the show you know such a good
moment and the fact that she hits him
for the fist and it's not like a spell
or something it's actually like a
physical hit there's something very
satisfying about that actually
originally said in the script that
Hermione slaps Draco I think they were
worried that a punch was going to be a
little too physical so I said to him I
don't want to run this we should
rehearse it we should make this as
convincing as possible slapped me she's
like now I'm not gonna say let's go on
slap me right now let's just do this to
good emotions what I said slapped me I
was like movie slap me I probably should
what I feel terrible I feel really bad
I'm not really sure what I was thinking
she just went and just smacked me right
across the face which completely took me
I didn't know what to do I was just like
yeah that was that was really good that
was that was great and kind of walked
off sheepishly